.
CRIME, HOMELESSNESS, HIGH COSTS
ARE ALL OF LIVING AT THE TOP OF
VOTERS MINDS.
HERE WITH THE VERY LATEST, HE'S
AT HIS OWN BIG BOARD, OUR OWN
BILL HEMMER.
WHAT'S INTERESTING OUT THERE IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
THESE VERY LIBERAL DAs IN A
COUPLE OF RACES GOING ON OUT
THERE.
ARE THEY GOING TO GET TOUGH ON
CRIME IN L.A., SAN FRANCISCO?
THAT SHOULD BE INTERESTING.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU, THAT'S
REALLY WHERE THE ACTION IS
TONIGHT AND THE SCREEN BEHIND ME
NOW, DEVON STATES WHERE THERE
ARE PRIMARIES BEING HELD.
YOU MENTIONED CALIFORNIA DOWN TO
SOUTH DAKOTA, A MOMENT AGO IT
WAS CALLED, KRISTI NOEM, SHE HAS
WON HER PRIMARY RACE TO BE -- TO
RUN AGAIN IN NOVEMBER AS
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
SOUTH DAKOTA.
REALLY AN EASY WIN FOR HER AS
YOU SCAN THE SCREEN HERE, I WILL
TAKE YOU ARE IN A MOMENT,
CHUCK GRASSLEY WON IS PRIMARY AS
WELL IN IOWA, SO AT THE AGE OF
88, HE WILL VISIT ALL 99
COUNTIES IN IOWA BETWEEN NOW AND
ELECTION DAY.
THE SAME THING HE'S DONE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME, THE SENATOR
THERE FROM IOWA.
WHAT'S GOING HERE A LITTLE BIT,
YOU MENTIONED CALIFORNIA.
WE WILL START OUT THERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE.
THIS IS SAN FRANCISCO, SO MUCH
ATTENTION FOR THE PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES THAT HE'S INITIATED
GOING BACK TO THAT JANUARY OF
2020.
WHAT'S ON THE BALLOT?
CRIME AND HOMELESSNESS RIGHT
NOW, THE FATE OF THIS
PROGRESSIVE D.A.
AND LOOK HERE, SEAN.
THIS IS 2020 IN YELLOW AND 2022
IN RED, YOU SEE WHERE THE
ASSAULTS WENT UP A LITTLE
HIGHER, AUTO THEFT WENT HIGHER,
LARCENY THEFT IS JUST OFF THE
CHARTS FOR A TOTAL CRIME RIGHT
BEFORE UP ABOUT 10%.
THIS IS REALLY THE STORY IN
PLACES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO, POLLS
CLOSE THEIR AN HOUR AND
20 MINUTES, WE WILL SEE IF HE
CAN HANG ON TO HIS OR NOT.
THAT IS SAN FRANCISCO.
GO DOWN THE COAST ABOUT TEN
HOURS, THIS IS L.A., THE MAYOR'S
RACE.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING.
KAREN BASS HAS BEEN IN CONGRESS
FOR SIX TERMS.
SHE WANTS TO BE THE MAYOR OF
LOS ANGELES.
SHE WAS LOOKING REALLY GOOD IN
THIS UNTIL RICK CARUSO CAME
ALONG.
HE'S A BILLIONAIRE, HE'S A
DEVELOPER.
THREE YEARS AGO HE WAS A
REPUBLICAN.
HIS RUNNING AS A DEMOCRAT.
CALIFORNIA'S RULES IN THE JUNGLE
RUNOFF IS THAT IF YOU DON'T GET
TO 50%, WELL, THEN YOU HAVE A --
HAVE A RUNOFF IN NOVEMBER,
MEANING YOU COULD GET TWO
DEMOCRATS ON THE TICKET, TWO
REPUBLICANS ON THE TICKET,
DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN.
WHOEVER THE TOP TWO VOTE GETTERS
ARE, THEY ADVANCE FOR THE
ELECTION NOVEMBER.
SEAN, LOS ANGELES IN 2020 WAS
CARRIED OVERWHELMINGLY BY
BERNIE SANDERS AND NOW THEY ARE
CONSIDERING THE POSSIBILITY OF
ELECTING A FORMER REPUBLICAN AS
THEIR MAYOR.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
CHECK OUT THE CRIME STATISTICS
IN LOS ANGELES.
2021 TO 2022, ROBBERIES ARE UP
IN RED.
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT UP IN RED,
TOTAL CRIME UP IN RED AS WELL.
AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE ARE
VOTING ON IN LOS ANGELES.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT TURNS OUT, AT
11 EASTERN TIME, AN HOUR AND
20 MINUTES FROM NOW.
GAS?
CALIFORNIA?
CROSS THE COUNTRY, $6.37 IN
CALIFORNIA, NATIONAL AVERAGE
$4.91.
I PAID $5.20 THE OTHER DAY IN
NEW YORK.
AGAIN, THE ECONOMY AND WHAT
CALIFORNIA WANTS IS A FUTURE.
QUICKLY I WILL GO THROUGH THIS.
THIS IS THE 22ND CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
WHY DO I POINT THIS OUT?
THIS IS A REPUBLICAN, HE VOTED
TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE'S
GOT SEVERAL CHALLENGERS, THREE
ON SCREEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOT ENDORSED
ANY OF THESE CHALLENGERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
TAKE YOU HERE TO IOWA, THIS IS A
TARGET REPUBLICANS THINK SUPER
VULNERABLE SEAT THEY THINK.
DEMOCRATS, UP FOR REELECTION IN
NOVEMBER BUT THEY REDREW HER
DISTRICT A LITTLE BIT,
DES MOINES IS RIGHT HERE AND
DOWN HERE IN THE AREA IN IOWA,
SHE HAS SOME BIG CHALLENGES ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN 2020.
SHE WON HER DISTRICT, BUT
DONALD TRUMP CLIPPED JOE BIDEN
IN THE SAME DISTRICT AND THEY
THINK THIS COULD BE A PICKUP FOR
REPUBLICANS IN NOVEMBER.
WE WILL BE LOOKING, SEAN, FOR
THE NEXT FIVE MONTHS NOW AT
THESE REPUBLICAN TARGETS.
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT'S 25, SOME
PEOPLE THINK IT'S 35.
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT COULD BE AS
HIGH AS 50.
WE WILL FIND OUT THE COMING
SUMMER MONTH END INTO THE FALL
BUT THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AS OF
NOW.
CALIFORNIA ONE HOUR AND
16 MINUTES AWAY TONIGHT.
>> Sean: BILL HEMMER,
PHENOMENAL JOB AS ALWAYS.
USED TO BE THAT HANNITY BIG
BOARD BUT YOU STO